yes sir thank you very much
yes I'm going to present a data science
approach to systemic risk and first of
all I would like to say that this is
joint work with Professor Sharon
O'Halloran from the Columbia University
in New York a student of hers of eating
suka mignon and Donna Gallagher the CEO
of quaternion okay so systemic risk is a
topic that is usually mentioned in
connection with the last financial
crisis and that is because the the last
financial crisis in oh 708 challenged a
fundamental assumption of finance and
that is that a triple-a rated bank
cannot fail a bank has failed and that
has caused massive economic damage the
problem with a bank failure is that it
not only causes this economic damage to
the to the direct clients of that bank
banks trade heavily with each other so
there is a risk that one bank failure
could cause another could cause another
so there would potentially be a chain
reaction of bank failures that could
theoretically wipe out the entire
financial system and systemic risk is
describes vaguely the risk of that
happening or phenomena that make this
more likely so the reason why one bank
failure can cause another is really
because of this interbank market and the
there are various types of interbank
markets and the one that is always seen
as particularly critical is the
interbank derivatives market that is
because first of all this market is
massive so they are like estimates - to
see how big it is and you see numbers
that for instance like the total
aggregate notional of all interest rate
swaps in the world is something on the
order of magnitudes of like hundreds of
trillions so like really really big and
the second reason why this is so
critical is because banks use this
interbank derivative market to transfer
risks from one bank to another in a very
precise and controlled way
and that means that if one bank fails
this risk gets unleashed and bounces
through the financial system in a
completely uncontrolled and dangerous
way and this was recognized most vividly
after the financial crisis so these
derivatives have a credit risk
inherently in them and therefore there
has been a regulatory response to this
cell so regulators and decision making
bodies all over the world have addressed
this issue and as a result financial
regulation God's changed and I really
have to say this so this actually
happened yeah you often hear read people
saying nothing has changed since the
crisis and that is not true on financial
regulation has changed what is and it is
not really in dispute so everybody who
works in this field technologist that
they have been changes but then also
gets much less clear and there's much
less consensus on the question on
whether or not this regulation has
actually been for good and if this
regulation is sufficient so you can ask
the question could a crisis on that
scale happen again this exact crisis
cannot happen again but we really would
want to decide whether or not the
financial regulation which we have now
is sufficiently safe and sound to avert
further crisis the problem why that is
not easy to answer is because the main
tool that is usually used to answer
these questions is expert judgment and
that's not surprising I mean it's a very
complex field that requires a lot of
practical experience to really
understand it so it kind of makes sense
that you ask an expert
the problem with expert judgment in any
field is what do you do if your experts
actually disagree and in in that
instance for for financial regulation
that has a systematic reason it has many
reasons but one that is particularly
pressing the field that's responsible to
settle these questions is financial
economics and that field is split
historically into two
views of the world microeconomics and
macroeconomics so in case you're not an
economist I'm I'm not an economist I'm a
mathematician um so I'll try to explain
this and probably oversimplify a bit and
maybe we look at this at a picture the
difference between micro and macro
economics is that they look at the
financial systems on different levels of
aggregation in microeconomics you
typically look at a bank and look at
this one bank in all its complexities
and especially in all the risks that
this Bank is exposed to as a result of
all their trade portfolios and because a
bank is massive and very complex the
next sense that you study this in in one
field the types of risks that you
typically look at are very well defined
and standardized here and there are are
things like market risk credit risk
liquidity risk this is all very well
defined what that is and the metrics in
which these risks are measured are
standardized and globally enforced by
regulators so for instance for market
risk you might have heard of like a
Value at Risk if you say I measure my
market risk and value at risk everybody
knows what that is and also this this is
a very corporate practical problem yeah
every major bank in the world has a has
a risk department that computes the
risks in their derivatives portfolio on
a daily basis and make sure that the
capital reserves allocated to buffer for
these types of risks are adequate so
this view is great it basically has
everything the only thing it doesn't
have is the other bank so you only ever
look at this one bank and you look at
the financial system from this one
perspective that makes it very hard to
study systemic effects and therefore in
macro economics you look at the
financial system as a whole and you look
at all these various banks in there but
for each and every one of that of these
banks you do not go too much into detail
and because this is a different field it
looks at this at this financial system
and at all these things
here these guys came up with the notion
of systemic risk and the reason why I
put that on quotation marks in the first
slide is actually so there isn't there's
a published report that's called a
survey of systemic risk from the US
Office of Financial Research and that
report has 31 metrics of systemic risk
and they collected every risk metric
people have been coming up with and that
means systemic risk is actually a much
less well defined notion than all these
micro economic types of of risk and
these are not just different metrics
these are really different aspects and
the big problem with most of these
metrics is the relationship between
these macroeconomic systemic risk
metrics and these micro economic
enterprise level metrics is often not
very clear and it's not easy to say how
how these affect each other
the problem which you have as a
regulator is you cannot regulate a
system you cannot regulate a market and
tell it to do this or to do that you can
only ever regulate a single entity and
that makes this very difficult to make
this gap perfect I mean banks are
typically private institutions whereas
this year is typically practiced in
central banks or in regulatory bodies or
at universities and these are often
public institutions so you don't have a
cultural gap between the two the reason
why this split occurred historically is
simply because if you want to study the
entire financial system from from that
macro perspective and go into every
possible detail of every bank then this
is too complex and too much data but
actually I have heard there's something
called Big Data now and there's this
programming language Python yeah that's
really good with this so the data
science approach to this would be this
we just take everything and look at this
now that that sounds like a good idea
and that sounds easy to do but
unfortunately this problem is
simultaneously a big data problem and
this simultaneously also a no data
problem
because if you would want to do this you
would really if you would want to
understand the financial system and the
risks in there as an aggregation of all
the micro economic risk metrics in all
these trends you would need to go to
each and every one of these things oh
can you please give me a trade data and
then each and every one of these banks
will say no and therefore you can't do
that of course you could try to ask the
regulators or can you give me these
high-level aggregated things but all of
this is going to be difficult and a
legal nightmare so we're not going to do
that imagine a situation where you would
need this so you are a regulator and you
would want to change financial
regulation and want to understand does
that make any sense unless you massively
overfit what you actually want that your
answer depends too much on the current
financial trade data you have to take
the time scale it into account here so
the financial crisis is 10 years ago by
now and the regulation I'm most
interested in is called initial margin
and that is still being phased in and it
will take to the early 2020s until it's
fully implemented it's actually knowing
all the trade data today is not helpful
in order to understand the effect of
this rip this regulation will have when
it's first going to be implemented it
will need the data from the future which
you don't get and so the idea is we
don't need we don't use the the actual
trade data because we don't need it what
we need is we just need some financial
systems we can play with so we use a
simulation technology to generate and
simulate entire financial systems and
try to understand the effect different
financial regulations have on risk in
that system and try to understand if
this makes the system more or less
stable so the concrete questions I want
to study is we we should first look at
the regulation that is already being
implemented or has been implemented
since the crisis and try to understand
if that has actually had the desired
effect of reducing systemic risk a
second question
how can we predict the impact of
financial regulation before implementing
it on an actual financial system that
would be really great right um
we would want to know what's the effect
of a regulation before trying it out
that's the current process with
financial regulation actually every
every law right it's hard to say what
will be the effect of implementing a law
without without implementing it and
simulation could help you obviously if
one would combine the two or one could
even try to ask the question how can we
find the best possible financial
regulation and that is actually what we
would want in in the very end okay so
that's the idea here and the data
science approach and the technology
solution we have used looks like this so
that's the architecture and I'll walk
you through the various steps in detail
first of all we need a generator we need
to be able to generate ideally realistic
sample of all possible future financial
systems and store these financial
systems in the database in order to do
that we need a mathematical model of a
financial system so we have a data
format in which we can store the
financial systems in the next step we
have to compute so that we're here and
in a next step we have to compute the
risks of every trait of every bank in
every financial system and then we have
a lot of risk later and then in the next
step we need to organize this data and
sort of feed that into our into our
graph model and if we've gone through
this process once well then we can
actually change the regulation under
which the risk is actually computed and
then in the last that we can aggregate
all this information and try to come to
to a conclusion and and come to an
answer true to the questions which I
listed before so let goat into these
components in in a bit more detail the
first thing would be to randomly
generate financials
systems as graphs I don't want to
discuss that in too much detail actually
um because that's a very complex but
actually very exciting field in in
discrete mathematics I have to resist
the temptation of of explaining this in
too much detail I didn't know that this
is under such active mathematical
research I mean finding algorithms to
generate large graphs with certain
properties efficiently is a very hard
problem for the purpose of this
simulation we use something which is
called the erase configuration model
because Network X actually just has that
implemented and then you can generate
graphs like this the property and trying
to capture here is that most financial
systems have the property that in their
in their trade relations there are a few
very very big players and lots of
smaller players around them so this this
graph model maybe I'll explain this in
more detail we model a financial system
as a graph by capturing the trade
relations in the financial system so the
graph consists of nodes and links and
the notes in that graph represent the
banks so in this example here we have
banks ABCDEF and there in this financial
system and whenever a bank a trades with
a bank B we add a link between them and
notice that this is an undirected graph
because trading with each other is a
symmetric relation that trade is only a
live deal if both science signs deal and
then we can attach the information about
these trains as as a data function to
these links so the easiest way to do
with this is you would simply attach a
list of trade IDs in the trade
portfolios between these banks and then
you can store all the details about the
trades in a trade database and by that
you have a model and a data
representation of an entire financial
system and all its traits in the
financial system okay so now all you
have to do is compute the risks in all
these complex
derivatives rates huh that is actually a
very hard problem I mean in decades of
research in in stochastic calculus and
in mathematical finance has been devoted
to compute to computing the risk in in
derivative portfolios so that's that's a
hard problem of course every bank does
have a risk Department and all these
major banks have their own systems and
models how to compute this but again we
can't rent these for that because these
systems are as proprietary and
confidential as the data that goes
through this and building such a system
from scratch is out of scope for for
such a research project so the way out
is we are using an open source risk
engine and this engine is called worried
and that computes the risk in a
derivatives portfolio from the
perspective of a single bank just like
in this micro economic case which we
discussed earlier and it does that um by
by consuming the trade data or some
market data at the configuration and
then does all this stochastic risk
factor modeling in a big Monte Carlo
simulation and in the end it gives you
these risk metrics this open source risk
engine is something that my firm has
developed over the years and we have
used this engine in various consulting
projects and from these projects we know
that the way we are doing this modeling
and the way we are computing this risk
metric is actually realistic it's very
easy for for a single trait to to
implement a prototype of a model and
understand the risk in these traits but
if you want to have something that can
run on on portfolios and now the
portfolio is an entire financial system
then this is actually quite a lot of
work with music in extensive
technologies thank in C++ it's based on
quantum and it has four hundred thousand
lines of code in total so I can't go
into too much detail via the way we use
it in this model is something which I
discussed now on the on the next slide
so assuming we have this trade relation
graph what I want to do is I want to
use this engine to compute an Associated
risk graph and the way I do this is we
in this graph we just copy the notes so
the notes of the risk graph are the
exact same notes as in the trade
relation graph so now for each and every
trade relation between the bank a and a
bank B we replace the direct its trade
relation at the undirected trade
relation by two directed arrows so you
see an arrow from A to B at an arrow
from B to a and that represents the risk
that a induces on B and vice versa as a
result of their trade portfolios and
then we introduce a weight function on
these arrows that measures the risk in
these trades in in a certain metric in
one or several of these standardized
risk metrics and in this example so here
I'm notice that this is not symmetric
this is 537 million this is 491 million
that is because the same trade can have
different amounts of risks from two
perspectives okay so and we run this for
if we just if you run this for one Bank
where we can run it for all these banks
and then we can fill this entire graph
with loads of of numbers and then we
have all these risk metrics and can look
at this financial system and see all the
risks everywhere now we might want to
aggregate this data first from the
arrows to the notes and then maybe from
the notes even to the to the entire
system and there's an it's an easy
purely graph theoretical way of doing
this you might have heard of the degree
in the graph and we used a weighted
version of this so basically the weight
is out or in degree is is this here so
that let's look at this example over
here so though the weighted in degree is
the sum of all the weights on these
arrows that go into a note and the out
degree is the sum of all the weights on
these arrows that go out of a note so
you can compute this in every graph that
that
has these weights on these arrows but
here this has a concrete interpretation
so a micro economist would say oh this
weighted in degree is very interesting
because for a single for any given
knowledge it tells me the amount of risk
this Bank receives from the entire
financial system so the this is all the
risk this Bank is exposed to and that is
so the worst that can happen to this
Bank from the perspective of this Bank a
macro economists would say oh this out
degree is very interesting because that
actually gives us the total amount of
risk this Bank induces into the
financial system so in other words that
is the type the the the amount of risk
that gets unleashed if this Bank goes
bust so we have both views the micro and
the macro economic view in one
consistent graph model on this note
level and then we can go even one step
further I mean we can of course sum of
all these values on all the errors in
the entire graph and then we have the
entire risk in the financial system that
is modeled by that graph I say that is
in itself a useful metric of systemic
risk it's a risk in the system and this
number is helpful because you can
express the risk that is received or and
used by any node as a percentage of the
total risk in the system and that is
what you see here these are the put
these percentage values so in this
example 47 percent of the risk in this
financial system is actually induced by
this one single bank and then a
regulator would say okay this is a
systemically relevant entity okay so
this and this is actually it yes so I
have taken you from from from here to
here to here to here and in order to get
to the results we have to choose some
regulations which we can feed into here
to test this setup okay so let's go
let's go here so in the interest of time
I don't want to go too much into the
details of all these regulations because
they're actually quite complex if
there's time in the end and you actually
want to know I can
gives you a bit more background on these
regulations for the experts this is the
these are the variation and initial
margin collateralization
of derivatives and roughly you can think
of the first one is a kind of base
regulation and then roughly of this one
as the first attempt to reduce risk and
this is a regulation that is currently
being phased in to reduce it even
further that's the intent I skip this
one in the middle in the interest of
time so what we want to understand is
how long do these different regulations
affect the financial system and we
really want to understand this now on
all levels of aggregation yeah for a
given regulation we want to answer this
question has this reduced risk or not
and if yes by how much and we want to
see how does this play out in the
various financial systems for the
various players in their and and their
portfolios and to do this we need to set
a few parameters so the risk type which
I'm interested in in this simulation is
credit risk and I measure this in a
metric which is called EE PE from that
stands for effective Iced expected
positive exposure um and that simply
tells you how much you're going to lose
if your counterparty goes bust okay then
we choose a few trade types in this case
it's I our FX derivatives and the
simulation results which I'm showing you
here's our our first prototype that
actually is not super big it's ten
financial systems each of them with less
than 50 banks and we have a few thousand
freights the reason for that is with
this setup I can run this our recent
donation on my notebook and produce the
the results and here they are
so this is a level of aggregation that's
even higher than the macroeconomics yeah
we look at the total average risk across
all financial systems which we generated
and we see here the space regulation the
risk is relatively high if we look at
this variation margin regulation we see
there's a big reduction on this total
average risk from from here to here
about seventy five percent and if we
compare it to this more recent one the
risk reduction is even higher okay so
that result is aggregations from from
all these various levels and because all
the data that is feeding into this
result is computed via the simulation
and generated we can now actually drill
it down and understand this in a bit
more detail for instance we can be a
macro economist and look at an entire
financial system now we can just single
out one of these financial systems from
the simulation and say okay show me that
system under three different regulations
and in this plot here the the notes are
bigger if they induce more risk into the
system so you can really see in this
base regulation there are various big
players that induce a lot of risk and if
you go from here to here to here you see
how these notes actually shrink and now
you can drool so we can make this
optical impression quantitative here so
we can actually look at these twelve
banks in that system and take this this
micro economic perspective and say so
for each and every one of this Bank how
does this look like for me and then you
see from for all of these banks you
actually see a reduction in risk
sometimes it's this reduction is a
little bit bigger sometimes it's a
little bit smaller but you can see this
for each and every one of these banks so
you would draw the conclusion that this
regulation is sufficient in order to
reduce total levels of risk what's
interesting you can also compute this
relative distribution of risk and you
see this over here and actually under
most of these regulations because the
reduction is rendered
even the the concentration of risk
across these things actually doesn't
really change or if it changes it
doesn't necessarily change for the
better
so this regulation is not suited to
reduce concentration risks at all so
that's that's the view on the bank level
but I mean we are we are now data
scientists right so this was derived
from from thousands of trades and
hundreds of trade portfolios and now we
can do data mining across multiple
financial systems on these portfolios so
let's do that what you see here on the
left-hand side is a comparison between
this base regulation and this variation
margin regulation and what I've simply
done is I've computed the relative
reduction in risk and plotted a
histogram over all portfolios in all
these systems and on the left-hand side
is pretty much what you would expect
right you see lots of portfolios have a
large reduction in in in risk but that
is actually quite interesting here so
there are a few portfolios that have an
increase in risk and so that is not the
effect you would want to have with that
regulation now you can already see how
how that conflict is is is playing out
right so you have someone on the highest
level of aggregation saying that's a
really good idea you have a portfolio
manager over here and he will have a
completely different opinion on the
affect of that regulation but because we
can jump between these levels of
aggregation we can now actually ask the
question okay how material is this and
that is done over here and so this graph
here shows you that this 74 percent
reduction which we saw in the beginning
is actually the sum of a large decrease
in risk plus a very small increase in
risk and that means then these cases
over here these are immaterial corner
cases that actually don't contribute
much to the total risk in the system so
we're actually safe in in this metric
here we see that the effect is the one
we would like to have okay so that's
basically the results of this
there's the results so I mean for for
this regulation we see it has the
desired effect it reduces total level of
risk but not so much the concentration
we saw a few of you corner cases and
from a technical perspective I think
what's most interesting is this overall
approach works that was less obvious to
me in the in the beginning this this
risk engine was not built for systemic
risk but for individual risk and we used
that in this in this architecture which
I'm showing it's shown you earlier so in
in this one that you plug it in here
that all this actually works in
combination with with this Python
technology stack of course there's lots
of further research that that can be
done we would like to carry out a larger
scale simulation there is a larger scale
simulation and what actually be really
interesting is to add more types of risk
here so in this graph which I've shown
you is one metric UPE of credit risk and
here you get the unambiguous result that
introducing these regulations is a good
idea what is what I think it would be
very interesting is to add also
liquidity and operational risk to that
simulation because it has been suggested
that actually this risk has increased
and then you need a quantitative answer
by how much has the one risk increase
and the other one being reduced and
obviously there's some best more than
this collateralization regulation maybe
you have heard of it and there's
something called central clearing and
that's another type of regulation that
could be plugged in into this graph
model you basically at one central node
in between all of them and then study
how this simulation changes I'd like to
say a pic so this this is a very complex
topic and there many more details one
could discuss it's a published research
papers in case you want to go deeper
feel free to take a look or talk to me
afterwards this collaboration between US
and Columbia University is is done in a
fin tech lab which has done more
research on systemic risk so feel free
to check that out so my farm is
battalion Risk Management and we are
hiring so in case you wanted to become a
risk management consultant you can talk
to me
after the after the talk and in case you
want to try out the risk engine you can
download it on github or check out this
initiative behind it and if you're
interested in this initial margin
regulation we've published actually
several papers on that as well a big
thank you to my to my co-authors for
this for this great work thank you very
much to PI data for for inviting me and
thanks to you for attending this talk
Thanks yes keep you some intuition for
like those corner cases where the the
risk exposure increased as a result the
regulation like because you said you
could see them but could you sort of
like explain what that position look
like or kids like if I can then I have
to tell you a bit more about these
regulations do we have time right okay
that that should work okay so these
these regulations so that you you want
to understand the difference between
this one and this one and understand why
it often has the desired effect and
sometimes it doesn't
yeah that's that's the question yeah
okay so what do these regulations
actually say so I mean if you have a
derivatives contract yeah that the
reason why this has any credit risk at
all is basically because the contract is
entered into right now right so if we
would enter into a contract we would set
the terms and conditions now and that
contract would say that there will be
payments in the future if one of us
default the payments don't happen and
that's dangerous and that was the
situation before so if we would have
some contract there's usually payment in
the beginning and often the payment in
the end but even if this contract runs
for years and years and years there
might be nothing in between so if the
markets move this contract might be
super valuable let's say for you and
then it would be really annoyed if I
default just before you get your payment
the regulation this variation margin
regulation that says the following so if
we enter into this contract then the
next day this contract will be worth
something either for me or for you let's
say it's a hundred thousand and this
states I just have to pay you a hundred
thousand as collateral into a collateral
account the next day the markets might
have changed and then maybe it's just 90
thousand when I call you and say I want
ten thousand back and we do this over
the entire lifetime of the trade till
the very end
and then we we settle with the final
payment with with the collateral the
reason why this greatly reduces risk is
obviously I mean if I give you this
money and I default well then you don't
have my derivative the derivative with
me but you have the money and that's
much better than having nothing the
situation is a bit more complicated if
if I compute my risk towards you and the
trade is in the money for you
then you have all this money from me
if we don't collateralize you have a
derivatives contract that's worth that's
worth nothing to me
but worth something to you and that
means if if you default I don't care but
now because you have my collateral and
you default you take that with you yeah
and that might actually be a situation
of the type I just described the markets
have been in your favor over the past
but they move back in my favor so I will
constantly call you give me collateral
back give me collateral back give me
collateral back and if you default while
I call you then I lose this collateral
and I would not have lost it if we just
said okay there is no collateral at all
but it is very rare that this daily
difference is actually larger than then
these values and for that reason that
occurs really really rarely so for
deeply out of the money portfolios that
are just recovering it's it's rare okay
provisions in the regulation which gets
added or drop like the dodd-frank or
dilution of dodd-frank do you think
there's a case to be made that a lot of
provisions of your modeling should be
made public like if let's say somebody
is tinkering with the oldest imagining
regulation yeah they should probably be
aware as a regulator what is going to
impact or if the political will comes
and goes to maintain that regulation
they should have the impact available in
a more transparent manner before they
take that call in whatever political
spectrum they take yes of the advantage
of having
situation where the where the model is
is transparent right and this open
source engine is is open source and the
data is completely generated means that
this can serve to provide some
objectivity to to discussions like this
right and that would be that's the aim
of this to to contribute to this okay oh
I'll difficult but we over there for
coffee
[Applause]